[Music]
14 years after you fell in love with the
Incredibles your favorite super family
returns with an all-new adventure
featuring surprise twists that will keep
you guessing unless you remember
anything at all about the first movie
you can't count on anyone especially
your heroes super heroes keep us week
safe bed actually Pixar's target demo
was Jack Jack sage back then Incredibles
two experienced fan favorite director
Brad Bird six feature film and is forth
about how regular Schmucks like us need
to suck it up and let the gift and play
by their own rules in a Pixar film that
continues their tradition of passable
sequels that don't hit the mark of the
first one except that one time when it
was even better and then one time when
it was so so much worse agent you mean
like insurance right like with The
Incredibles Bob is a dad who just wants
to turn his children into living weapons
while Helen just wants a collection set
piece of her own for once
last time they learn to trust each other
and fight crime as a family unit after a
mishap where one of the parents did
illegal hero work on behalf of a techno
genius who turned out to be a villain
and the public learned to love
superheroes again now after 15 minutes
of erasing all that progress watch the
pores learn to trust each other again
and fight crime as a family unit again
after a mishap where one of the parents
does illegal hero work again on behalf
of a techno genius again who turns out
to be a villain again and the public
learns to love superheroes again again
and if you think they're gonna mess with
this formula for the next one I can give
you 1.2 billion reasons why they won't
looking to spoil the fun is the evil
screensaver a villain who uses screens
to hurt people including the audience
she believes heroes are a dangerous
menace we shouldn't rely on which the
movie never really disputes
that's rocket launcher and has some
incredibly solid points about the harm
of society's non-stop consumption of
media pretty cos sweat participate and
which of course makes her the villain in
a Disney movie shut up evil lady that
wants us to go outside real heroes are
already subscribed to Disney streaming
service look at all that IP oh yeah give
me all of that IP man I want to bathe in
it so enjoy a film but the exact same
dynamic is the first time around that's
still incredibly charming and holy moly
does it look good but after 20 films
have another Pixar movie is a chasing
for a climax I'm gonna dash myself up a
cliff
[Music]
can be sick stop chasing there's other
ways to end a film you know why did you
switch things up with a huge world
ending threat that like menaces people
by projecting some kind of like sky beam
or something
wait what am I saying I've become when I
hate the most
nevermind chase away to infinity and
beyond starring down with a thickness
triangle man triangle man streaks and
Geeks cash cash phantom threatener
Samuel Elsa Jackson Bob the old Dan Kirk
and Catherine Keener just really wanted
to play another hypnotist run run super
smash bros sisters moms and dads you
have your Incredibles everyone knows
Jack Jack has powers we found out in the
last movie and Ric digger found out from
the babysitter and Jack Jack Attack kind
of surprised you didn't clue you in on
all this that's a real rig dicker move
rig dicker as a funny name George
Clooney was a Batman of insufficient
quality yeah I said it
without cookies him just a monster thank
you for nothing
you useless reptile gummy gumdrop stops
pops in your epic voice who's a good
doggy
you are yes you are